[Music]
hi everyone welcome today to
grandmaster's choice
a woman grandmaster italia cervantes and
i'm guessing just by the title you're
supposed to just choose something and i
really wanted to get talking about the
the olympiad ride the olympia going on
in chennai
and
i feel like almost everybody i talked to
within the chess community i'm like did
you watch the games today did you see
this result um how do you feel about
this team and that team and did you see
this player it's scoring so well
and
yeah so i just wanted to bring that here
and there are a lot of highlights um
there were a lot of highlights
especially in today's round
uh there are two teams who are still in
the open section two teams that are
still with a perfect score it's the
indian b team or the second team that
they have since they're the hosts they
get to have multiple teams and
the other one is
armenia actually
um so those two teams are certainly
at the top and they're going to fight
for first place tomorrow
and thai there are a bunch of teams with
i guess you can call it four and a half
out of five
because they won all their matches and
drew one
we have the us we have
kazakhstan
if i'm not mistaken
you have
iran
and i think india india the first indian
team yeah so but another one another
team that i thought has been doing a
really great job so far is the cuban
team actually and i wanted to talk about
it
um i'm familiar with most of the players
and
they kind of range between 25 20 and 25
50 in rating so their team average i
think it's about 25 52
but
they
played against
uh they played against
who was it um against hungary yesterday
and hungary has a very strong team they
actually defeated hungary
um
they drew against ukraine in the
previous match up and i mean ukraine is
one of the top
top countries so that was amazing
and today they played against azerbaijan
who had a
team rating of about twenty six eighty
they had mamajarov in their lineup and
the cuban team actually won which is
amazing right it's like so
so surprising so
yeah i just wanted to go over some of
the games
and take a look at the at how the cuban
players were
doing today
so the
first game that i wanted to go over was
from board two
uh it was
uh carlos daniella bonos he is i believe
number two in the country he is
an ex
q1 champion um i don't think he wanted
this year but maybe last year
and
he's also very young he's 20 years old
or maybe like 21 years old
and
obviously it's kind of like the rising
talent of the of the country
and i feel like this game against
mamadov kind of only
uh reinforces this idea
um
so
let's just go ahead and get started with
the game we have our bonus with the
white pieces it's maybe a little too far
from the screen but you can kind of see
the rating difference albernos has 2566
and mamadou has 26.56 so and it's those
are um 90 points right of rating
difference
and it started off from a especially
cough
um this line
obviously was popular before but i got a
lot of notoriety as well during the
world chess championship in 2018 which
was uh fabiana caruana against magnus
carlsen a lot of the games had the
debate in this in this line
and after knight 2 f6 knight c3
e5 knight 2 b5
pawn to d6
the idea essentially as we're going to
see it is that white gets a really solid
control of the square on d5 but black is
gonna try and find counter play
especially on the keen side right with
future ideas of um f5 f4 pushing forward
the
the king side so knight to d5 was played
takes takes knight to b8 the knight is
going to real group to d7 continue with
f5 probably put the knight on f6
pawn to
pawn to a4
usually
here is kind of a crucial moment for
white
you kind of have to be very careful in
what you do and a4 and c4 are both
main lines c4 is actually a little bit
more
popular
but kind of the point is that you don't
just allow a6 b5 from
from black and let them have space on
this side of the board as well
but pawn to a4 was played bishop to e7
bishop to e2 castle bishop to d2
and
right off the bat you know you can kind
of see that
that
um white house and castle jets just yet
they're kind of keeping that possibility
flexible
just to see what happens and after pawn
to a6
knight to a3
black did kind of a rare move for a
sicilian he went pawn to a5
um the idea of pawn to a5 is quite
simple if for example something like f5
had been played instead
then white is the one that gets to play
pawn to a5 with the help of this bishop
on d2 it almost looked like the bishop
wasn't doing so much but now you can see
the point it supports the pawn here on
a5 and the future idea is knight to c4
with some ideas of the knight getting in
a possible variation for example is
knight to d7
and after knight to c4 pawn to f4 bishop
to b4 putting pressure on this pawn
right here um even
the rook can swing up right it's a very
very nice idea
the rook can even come to c3 put some
pressure onto the screen you see that
black has very little space on the queen
side the pawn can come to f3 to stop any
any um expansions on the center and
kingside and from then on white is most
likely going to have a pleasant
pleasant position
so that was the point with a5 from
mamadov
and the only inconvenience that it has
is that it kind of gives the the square
on b5 back to
back to white right
so
uh
albernos decides to play bishop to b5
and after pawn to a5 going to e2
knight to d7 and knight to c4 and
you can see how
the
white pieces are
kind of shifting but in a way that
it doesn't look like they are
it doesn't look like they are just
maneuvering around senseless the bishop
on b5
uh kind of has some controls in this
diagonal it's in general just a lot
better than if it wasn't d3 or c4 right
just because of the e4 push
and
the knight coming to c4
puts pressure onto this phone here on d6
and we're gonna see some other future
ideas but essentially white has no
weaknesses in this position that black
can attack right it's just kind of
improving the pieces step by step
knight to c5 and now the one piece that
is no longer
doing something jumps to a better square
bishop to e3 right and
after let's say do you think that pawn
to f4 would be a
a good idea for black or
does white have a have a good
continuation now
actually yeah that works completely fine
i was thinking more of like d6
uh because
after bishop takes there's rook d1 or a
long castle and the bishop is under some
trouble but yeah essentially the the
pawn structure from black is getting
completely disrupted even if white is
giving up the the bishop right
um
so
queen to c7 was played
and now that the now that the queen is
defending the knight
and the idea of f4 is a lot more real
because this becomes a
a huge problem white is going to have
issues on the light squares from now and
the dark squares from now on
now that f4 is actually a thread white
decides to do it themselves they decide
to play pontiff for
just kind of blocking off the
the ideas
and after pawn to e4
the question is how to proceed here
how to proceed here as
a switch
what is going to be your plan
for the game
the idea that
white did in this game is very
innovative it's not the most popular
continuation
but
it does make a lot of sense and the play
is very practical once you start
thinking about it
some people in the chat are saying rook
a3 with like another
left some people are saying g4
shark castle
there are lots of ideas but the question
is
which one
did the grandmaster go for
some people are playing h4 as well
this one i understand a little less
uh
i guess the idea is h5h6 but i guess the
pawn can go to g6 after that
do you guys have any ideas
right
especially now that we played f4 and e4
was played taking the the knight
would lead to a lot of weaknesses
we kind of have two options right where
we can keep the position a bit more
you know um
normal i guess with shark castle
but there's also the possibility of long
castle right
and the question is which one
which one seems more
i guess more
desirable right because
they have different ideas and usually in
this position
uh white castle short there are some
interesting games actually one of them
being
um
what's their name
one of them being
nothing back against uh gookash who are
funny enough the two guys in this
olympiad who have a perfect score so far
um
and the
the move that
abernez decided to go within this
position was casa long
and the idea is that okay
i know usually when i castle this side
black plays for an attack and they can
open up the position very easily but
you're not going to
get to do that
this game and i'm gonna start playing
with h3g4 opening up that side of the
board
and
i'm gonna go for an attack so that's
essentially what he's saying right it
kind of makes the position a little bit
more practical and and it does make
sense because this fashion cup is one of
those lines that are very rare in the
sense that
black actually plays more on the king
side and we can see that here right
where the most advanced pawns are
um so it makes sense to put the key into
safety right to try and bring it to
to this side of the board
and then play for an attack towards this
king right
white has most of the control of the
light squares the pawn on the pawn break
on b5 is not as strong when the pawn is
not on a6
right so
essentially black is a white is saying
come at me and
try to do something while i open up the
position the key inside
so it was just a very innovative very
interesting idea from white
and black decided to play with bishop to
d7 tried to trade off those bishops
another possibility was bishop f6 for
example i feel like this move looks
natural
but after something like king to b1
um it's just a position white is a
little bit more comfortable
uh just because of the space advantage
but
the position is still playable and once
again the idea is h3 and g4
but the move bishop to d7 allows white
to have a really interesting
really interesting um
tactical resource it didn't actually
happen in the game
but
there is a tactical idea here
for
for white that
puts them with a very big strategical
advantage
bishop takes knight
um
i mean of course the queen cannot take
it and it won't take serious d6
so the main question is what happens if
bishop takes
bishop to expand
and i guess
well i guess i could go for this train
and after it takes sticks and black and
sub the piece up
so that might be
a problem
i mean you probably have to go for this
bishop takes takes and then take this
one and then either queen takes or
pontex context leads to d6 so maybe not
that
but um
queen takes and i feel like the fact
that the a file is now more open and the
pumpkin push can be
a little bit scary for white
but there are some ideas of like
forcing some exchange to happen
and white ends up
ahead strategically
knight to e5
knight 285 i think
i think we're going to straight up
take
because if you play d6 i'm gonna take
with the bishop
oh unless you want to do like bishop
takes c5 now
and if bishop takes something like group
d7 and if queen takes bishop d7
uh
but then i guess bishop takes happens
and after a few takes we should takes we
should take special texts
it's a little complex right like it's a
lot of moves to look ahead
um
but maybe not through e5 but a different
square
it takes d6 i don't think this works
because a bishop takes
and everything is going to be protected
just enough
but we can try to set up some pins here
yeah and then b6 actually and the point
is that after queen takes we get bishop
takes d7 and the knight cannot take back
because of um the queen hanging right
and if y gets the pair of bishops in
this position right and the
power to even go to e6
if if um we want to
is very very strong so uh
this bishop can come to d5 pawn can come
to g4 once again and the position is
just a lot more dominant for for white
obviously we didn't get any material
from this tactic but it just leads to a
much better strategical position
and i kind of really like those tactics
uh
because it ends up being
um it ends up being
kind of unexpected sometimes
but yeah knight to v6 would have been a
really nice move
um however the idea that white one for
here is also completely fine which is
bishop takes d7 knight takes d7 and now
he's thinking
okay my nano c4 is really nice but it
doesn't actually have a
it doesn't actually have any target
right now any anything that it can
attack
and i want to make sure i don't allow
any pawn breaks on this side of the
board otherwise i'll give my opponent
counter play
so he decides to play knight to a3 and
the idea is very simple the knight is
just going to b5
it ever wants to from b5 it can go into
d4 and e6
um
just a future
future idea and
um yeah once a night gets to b5 king
goes to b1 there's not much that black
has to attack right like it's very
difficult to break through in the
in in the queen side
so this was played
and rook ac8 came to b1 knight to c5
knight to b5
uh both players are making pretty normal
moves the pawn on
uh the pawn on a4 is hanging so b3 was
played
and the whole the whole point the whole
thing is that
okay um
how
how is black going to make use of the
fact of me moving my
my
pawns in front of the king right because
the bishop can come to f6 if it wants to
that's what that was the next move
actually but it doesn't have any target
into this diagonal either right
um so white is just going to
start the idea on the keen side now that
everything is consolidated on the other
side of the board
so pawn to h3
knight two a6
pawn to g4
and black
kind of i feel like black mamadov
started um kind of worrying a little bit
once
they got to this stage of the game
because
his moves begin to be a little bit
rushed so
for example after
knight to c7 takes takes pawn to c4 was
played
and the whole idea is that there are no
going to be any pawn breaks right
um
but mama though if you know being an
aggressive player he went for
b5 anyways
i mean this is kind of a practical move
you're also playing it against a
grandmaster so a grandmaster who
probably calculated b5
so you must assume that in most of the
variations white is going to be just
fine
another move would have been bishop to
c3
and it kind of does make sense but after
it takes takes and queen to c2 we have a
double attack right
so
there are just a lot of issues with the
black position
but after pawn to b5
a takes b5 pawn to a4
and the main question is can we take
this right here
would that be a good idea
the queen can take on c4
but if the queen takes on c4 i mean
you're kind of also trading off queens
and i feel like this is gonna be
okay for
for white now that the king is no longer
in any danger
um maybe i can play something like
something like rookie two i would say if
i'm not getting checkmated
maybe i am
but i'm guessing maybe they can try to
cover
something like this
and i mean there are still two pawns
that you need to take care of to be fair
you can take off one of them but the
pawn once this pawn reaches b6
the position is you know going to still
be
in favor of white just because of that
past pawn
there is a way that you can continue
with the attack with the queens on the
board
and b takes a4 like completely takes
away all of are vintage and gives it to
black
okay eight is possible but there is a
better piece so we can bring forward
ryan
yeah going to a5 right and uh next move
well of course the pawn is hanging but
next move is also going to be four
right and after going to b4 rook takes
c4 is coming and the position is
completely collapsing so for example if
queen c2 claim b4 and rook takes c4 and
white is completely lost
so it's very important not to give in to
you know just the material that is being
offered to
to you at the moment
and
uh
white player knew this and he played
pawn to b6 kind of an intermediate move
to prevent
any queen a5 ideas and after
queen to b7 b4 right keeping the
position mostly closed
around his skin
and after queen a6 rook c1 all that y
needs to do here is consolidate make
sure the blacks attack is completely
neutralized and if they manage to do
that
they're kind of just winning the game
because of the
the amount of pawns that they have right
and how their passports
so after pawn 2 a3 king 2 a2
not allowing anything
group 2 b8 rook to c2
and
now it's just the time to start offering
trades right and for whatever exchange
of queens that
uh black decides to go for white is
going to be completely winning because
of the past bonds
so queen a4 was played and then c6 queen
takes b4 rook to b1 and just a couple of
moves after
my weight off decided to resign
move 38
and it's literally impossible to stop c7
and the position is just completely
crashing for white it's a little crazy
it's almost like black was just so close
but they never
could make the pieces work into a real
attack for
for white
so this was actually a very quick
victory for
um
carlos daniela buenos and
i think by the time i woke up this game
was over and i mean the game started i
don't know what time exactly maybe like
6 a.m and i woke up at around 8am and uh
this game was over by then usually
grandmasters games you know they take a
bit longer like three hours four hours i
mean like longer than
let's say master level games
uh but
yeah this was relatively a quick game
and
the exciting part is that not only was
this a win but for three on board four
were winning for cuba as well right
uh board
four
it had omar almeida and he is like 25 20
something right now but he's kind of
like
legendary kill and grandmaster and he
actually had a winning queen end game um
i think it was
uh two versus two on one side of the
board and then on the other side he had
a past pawn
and he was going with his skin his queen
was protecting and he had that postpone
that would have been really nice if he
you know managed to to win the end game
i'm pretty sure he could have traded
queens at one point and get into a
winning opponent game
but he ended up making a draw and that
was okay because um next game
uh was vasif duraveli from
azerbaiyan he actually
he actually uh lived here a couple of
years ago he went to webster university
and with the black pieces is uh
lusa neto quesada perez
uh
something really funny uh
in the cuban team there are two players
with the last name
perez and a lot of people may think
they're siblings uh they are not i think
they're from the same town but they're
not siblings but board one yes sir
quesada he is uh his brother
um is another grandmaster like 2600
level grandmaster and he lives here in
san luis so it's kind of like a
funny funny
like coincidence i guess
but
yes so going over the
the
um
board 3 game i kind of want to
focus more on the end game but
uh
i will show the game from the start it
was a night off
and
don't we all just love neither bishop to
e3 uh
e5 was played another variation it can
be a little tricky sometimes it's knight
to g4 if anyone is interested
but after pawn to e5
the knight has two options right most of
the times the knight goes to b3 but in
this game the knight went to f3 and
essentially the idea is that it leaves
the square of b3 for this bishop and it
has the idea to come to c4 get onto the
nice diagonal since black decided to
play pawn to e5
and whenever the bishop goes to e6 then
it can jump to g5 that's kind of the
point
so bishop to e7 was playing the game
bishop to c4 castle castle everything
looks
quite natural
and knight to a5 trying to get rid of
that bishop and bishop to d5 was played
this is a very interesting move you
usually don't see something like this
but the point is that if knight takes d5
the knight is going to recapture on d5
there is a very strong
outpost the pawn can go to c4 in the
future
and there are immediate ideas with
bishop to b6 making a
skewer i guess and then i can also
get rid of this bishop on e7 whenever it
wants
so since knight takes d5 is not possible
bishop to e6 was played group d1 queen
c7 rook ac1 uh personally i think the
smooth rook ac one is a little strange
obviously it looks to defend upon c2 in
some future especially because the
it makes sense to put the the black rook
here on the c file
um
i think it might it might
be due to the fact that
white didn't feel super comfortable in
the position
usually the square on d5
is for the knight right so usually in
this lines um let's say the bishop is on
sometimes it's on e2 sometimes i guess
it can be on b3 but usually it's the
knight going to d5 right and once the
knight goes to d5
uh
the pawn goes to either c3 or c4 in most
of the variations because black does
something like queen c7 rook c8 puts
pressure on the pawn so white plays c3
that's usually how these positions go
right
so i think due to the fact that the
knight is kind of stuck here on f3 on c3
and it doesn't have any way to improve
um
why just decided to play rook ac1 maybe
you know expecting in some future that
if black takes the knight takes and the
pawn is already covered
um but
it ends up kind of not doing too much in
the square for most of the
most of the game
it just looks kind of like an awkward
move
h6 was played overall this move makes a
lot of sense it prevents both ideas of
knight g5 and bishop g5 getting rid of
the main controller of the d5 square
just kind of a prophylactic move knight
to d2 was played
rook to c8 pawn to a4
queen d7 bishop to b6 and bishop to d8
and it is kind of in this position where
you wish the rook was on a1 so it could
be reinforcing this pawn here on a4
but it isn't and
the bishop going to d8 is a very typical
maneuver in the sicilian as well
especially you know if there is no dark
square bishop from white in this
diagonal they can go to b6 and get into
a
much better diagonal than here on e7
right
and the point is that if the bishops
actually trade after something like
bishop d8 root d8
uh the knight is going to come back onto
c6 and d4
so
that makes sense and overall the black
pieces just look a lot more centralized
and comfortable than the white pieces
right because again the bishop on the e5
is a little strange
the ruger c1 doesn't do too much and the
knight on d2 probably has to move once
again
you can go to c4 because you have too
many pieces attacking it right so
that's gonna be a piece lost
um but it's also not clear when the
knight is going to where the knight is
going to next it might just have to come
back to f3
uh but then something like knight two
knight two c6 and position is completely
fine for
four black
so again this position bishop takes e6
was played first spawn takes and bishop
takes takes
rook to b1
uh rook to v1 is another another move
that is
kind of awkward i think the idea may
have been something like pawn to b4 and
then pawn to b5 breaking through on this
side
but kind of the point
is that
the
black knight is not looking to retreat
itself to c6 but it also has some ideas
of going to c4 right especially now that
you move the rook away and there's less
pressure with
less protection over this file queen to
c6 was played
pawn to h3
and
rook to d7 just kind of keeping the
position
all together everything is safe
knight to f3 queen to b6
and after a couple of moves like rook to
d3 rook to c7
there are all of his certain ideas of
root takes c3 right take stakes
and
the position would be winning for for
black and the knight is also coming on
to c4
so knight to d2 knight c4 takes takes
queen e3 and then we get into this end
game
uh how would you guys evaluate this end
game
especially
i guess you know since you're looking at
it from the black perspective
how would this end game be because a lot
of times people are like oh you know we
got to an end game the
all of the problems are gone i can
probably draw this but
you still need to play with a lot of
activity in endgames
um
yes
especially in the
center pawns right they control a lot of
jumps
that
white may have and another reason why
black is better is again just because of
this pressure here on the c file it's
almost as if this knight won't ever be
able to move
uh because it protects this pawn and
this pawn and this one right it
it's um
it's the knight is going to be stuck
there there's no way to make progress
and the rooks won't have any great
square either i mean technically you can
start putting them on the d file
it does make a lot of sense but the pawn
will always be protected especially when
the king starts coming up
and this rogue also has to stay
protecting the spawn here on e4
so overall the white the black position
is
just a lot more comfortable to play
king to f7 was played
yeah so another idea in the future could
be playing b5 takes takes and pushing
the pawn to b4
we gotta see how that works so so
keen to f1 king to e7 root two
d1
rook to b4 trying to provoke some
weaknesses
pawn to b3 was played and rook to b6 and
essentially the rook just threatens to
come back and keep on putting pressure
on the c2 pawn
route d3 rook to c6 king 2v1
and now okay of course we have one
thread right we have one weakness that
we can put pressure on
uh from black
to white but
uh the point is that we're going to
create more right we need to create some
other weakness in the position so that
we can alternate between these two
problems that the opponent has
and
you know until it reaches a point where
it's almost impossible to to keep
everything under control
so from that
uh
black decided to play pawn to g5 and the
idea is quite simple they're going to
start pushing pawns on the other side of
the board create some weaknesses in the
in the king side and then start building
up so
kin to d2 pawn to h5 pawn to g3 and pawn
to h4
and the thing now is that if
white decides to keep the position more
close with something like pawn to g4
uh white black still has the idea of
playing rook to c5 and b5 that is still
completely playable however they also
now have the possibility of playing
knight d7 knight fade knight g6 and
knight to f4 and if if the black knight
gets to f4 the pawn on h3 will always be
a problem the rig on d3 is a little bit
stuck
so
it's just going to be a lot harder for
4y to play maybe we can even play
something like into f6 and prepare this
pawn to d5 break
so
g4 wasn't played but k2 e1 just trying
to keep the position
more flexible
rook to c5 king to f1 and after it takes
takes
pawn to
g4 and the funny thing is that if pawn
to h4
knight to h5 once again the knight is
the best blockader
um it puts pressure on the pawn on g3
and the pawn will never be able to
to become a queen
soaking to g2 pawn to b5 and you know
now that the now that we managed to get
the the white king fighter away right
remember that it had uh come closer and
maybe intended to protect opponent c2
now we've made it go back towards the
kingside the pawn on c2 is still weak
the two rooks are more stuck than ever
because of the pawn here
we start uh
going after
you know going for an invasion with pawn
to b5 and
threading some trades and pawn to b4
and the y position just collapses so
after takes takes
pawn to b4 rook to c4
now the opponent b4 is a massive
weakness and after it takes takes
picked up that pawn the other ones are
coming
and
as long as nothing hangs and we don't
allow the opponent to get any counter
play
the position is completely winning for
for black and after a couple more moves
just of maneuvering around and
you know the players were probably in
time trouble
uh the position just became totally
totally
lost for white we see that they play he
played actually rook c7 not even
allowing any checks but after rook two
before rook takes rook takes c2 it is
impossible to escape safely
the idea of rook to f3 checkmate
so
this was an amazing
um an amazing result not only for for
you know the individual players both of
them be 2 600 grandmasters that's
difficult to do at any level even if
you're at 2700
it's very difficult to defeat 2600s and
i mean actually if you look at the
olympia the lot of players were 2700
they're drawing a lot of games
i feel like that's just part of the
strategy right like as long as you don't
lose
um
you did a good job with your game
but
you know
like
if you want to win you gotta
go uh go for some initiative and you can
see that even with the black pieces here
um
the lowrider player managed to
completely outplay
wide and
like i said not only is it an amazing
individual result for those players but
also
um for the team and the cuban team ended
up winning two and a half two one and a
half against a server john
this uh pushes us everybody down further
down in the list i think they're on like
the spot 27th or something
and the q1 team is set to face spain
tomorrow who lost today
against um
the indian team there was a very
interesting game
in similar style to the first game we
saw today there was this game between
sheriff and in gukesh and essentially it
was just gookash with the black pieces
saying you're not checkmating me in this
position even even if my king is castle
long um
and that's what happened and he ended up
with uh with a win against shiro which
is massive right
taking into consideration that the other
day um on sunday for a double x time i
showed two share of games right so we
know how strong of a player he is
um but yeah so that's kind of all for
today
um i would recommend just everybody just
keep on watching the olympia i feel like
it's super exciting
uh the women's team
um i think the women's team for both
cuba and the us lost unfortunately
but it's amazing the peruvian team
defeated us and i mean i i i've known a
lot of peruvian players they they are
very strong
the female team is really strong they
have daisy corey as well who's kind of
like
legendary uh peruvian player and for
latin america and girls and all of that
so
yeah there are just a lot of upsets
going on there are a lot of interesting
games you can probably get a lot of
opening
novelties just by watching the games
from the event
and
yeah overall it's just like a very
unifying very exciting and
yeah it's just one of those tournaments
that everybody around the world watches
and
it always kind of leaves a big impact so
yeah that's all for today that's kind of
why i wanted to talk about it because
the olympus is just so exciting
um
but yeah thank you so much to everybody
who was online watching i guess i'll see
you all tomorrow with some play the
people or
some other arena
and
yeah have a good one
thank you
[Music]
you